hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
and I'm John Humphrey
we're gonna watch today a movie clip of
spider-man into this spider-verse
exclusive clip what's exciting about
this is apparently after looking at my
YouTube notifications a whole bunch of
people already put up their movie
reviews for it
we're not invited to press screenings
why would we I mean sure we have more
subscribers than a lot of our friends
who go to these presque readings but
we're not worthy were not worthy
Sonne what do you want and tell you what
I want I want you guys to download and
follow us for free and things free to
start us that people you see over there
with you 30 second reaction reviews for
films trailers and occasionally a TV
show so do it now because we post daily
on there some of them are micro sketch
is actually a pretty good amount we love
using that app and you will - there's
other famous people on there people who
are more famous than us and we're like
top of the tiers so you can only imagine
how big some of these other folks are do
it now because like when we cover
something like into the spider-verse you
best believe we're gonna have our
opinions there first not on Twitter not
anywhere else
baby do the big
[Music]
that is a real spider
[Music]
not have a shoe I think
[Music]
[Music]
I cannot wait to watch that oh wait a
minute oh [ __ ] I think tickets are out
hold on side kicks
let's get those ticks going on a list
right now I totally forgot to do that
spread I had this morning and then I
selected it but then I'm like something
went wrong with the app and I was like
all right I'll try it again in 15
minutes I didn't do it all right so
after much time of a kid Erie tickets in
sorted out got our tickets written to
the spider-verse
as I was watching this I was just enjoy
like I can't wait to watch this movie
this looks so awesome and then it hit me
a rabbit it was done that shizzle yes
I've heard amazing things about this
movie it's like a game-changer it was
like 10 seconds into here right where I
went he threw the bagel it's a bagel in
the background like really subtle it hit
me there's gonna be a lot of rewatch
ability with this movie oh it is so much
beyond like story points and references
and whatever there's gonna be so much
rewatchable 'ti in terms of little
animation nuggets that are just
sprinkled throughout and little details
here there that you won't notice the
further it's gonna be so much you're not
gonna notice yeah with sight gags and
clever yeah sure they're gonna be a lot
of Easter eggs too I'm sure people who
liked those things like our buddy Andrew
he's gonna be going nuts over that yeah
or even you know I think about channels
like mr. Sunday movies yeah I don't know
how I'll be able to watch this one time
and be able to get everything down
because it's gonna be sprinkled
throughout when we saw Venom's and this
is a spoiler if you haven't seen venema
for all this time it's not really a
spoiler but after the credits like the
actual after the credits are done
playing there's a thing that says
meanwhile in another universe and then
they proceeded to show us like a five
minute clip
into the spider-verse watching that was
a similar effect where I was watching
this clip where I found myself going
don't get too comfortable cuz it will
act between how beautiful all the
animation that is and just the energy of
it like this just looked like such a fun
scene and I can't wait to see Peter and
Miles like bond and you know yeah and
have Miles like kind of rise to the
occasion with Peter's tutelage like this
looked like a really fun and fun fun and
games kind of scene you know it's weird
because I feel like I already want to
review the movie and I've only seen two
clips and they're not like bad you know
edited clips like usually what you get
when they when people when Studios
release a clip online it's like so
obviously I know this is yeah but you
know watching the five-minute thing in
the theatres and then watching this the
trailers were already great but the
clips are even better and that's such a
good sign yeah the visual style too is
just so like I can't wait to see that
you know for the whole length of the
movie up on the big screen because these
little glimpses look really unique and
it's cool to be able to get excited
about something like that because we
don't get a ton of animated super movies
and seeing these clips and trailers and
stuff for this it almost feels like a
no-brainer that should happen more yeah
because you know this looks like a
beautiful vibrant comic book you know
and complete with all those little wacky
flips and bagel you know like a little
words that pop up and all that you know
well it seems to me executed so well to
the point where it doesn't feel like
it's gonna be annoying or frustrating to
sit through you look at kinetic but yeah
not like ear piercing not like annoying
yeah because something like this
sometimes could be like that's cool to
watch in a trailer or something or sure
but then you watch the movie you're like
too much oh yeah this is frustrating but
the pacing and the tone the way they're
handling it all from just the two clips
we've seen is like no this isn't
grossing you know which is a special
relieving feeling kids you know it's
like watching an under net computers
it's totally different feeling as
opposed to
Theater for them like but I saw a clip
in the theater it was amazing yeah even
further down like a very comic book II
hold to me with this whole like
alternate dimensions getting a bunch of
different versions of the character
together yeah I love that kind of stuff
from comics especially it's cool we got
like a moment at least with Spyder grin
at the end you know a little dialogue I
mean another another dimension I heard
that you know Sony's already working on
their spin-offs and sequels for this
horse you see that wasn't my reaction
surprisingly I was like like this might
be the one thing that they are able to
nail pro yeah I think they will I find
it very hard to believe they won't oh
yeah whatever reason I have a lot of
faith in this particular movie and I'm
not watching I mean like some of the
people I know have put up their reviews
for this movie and I'm like I'm not
watching it till we've shot our yeah I
might see like whatever the artsy score
is and some capsules yeah but I'm not
gonna actually watch other people's
reviews until the day of the
spider-man's one of my favorite hero is
and a movie like this like gets me
almost childlike except like a
spider-man live-action movie is a bit
different for me now where is this I'm
like I can't wait yeah popcorn will be
there you know like oh yeah yeah this is
gonna be awesome from where my
spider-man suit to the theater and
spider clone was in here speaking of
women oh I love women me too I like some
of them
I live in every woman but I like
everyman Picture of the Day shout-out I
want to give it to a lovely woman named
Adelia Chamberlain Adelia we've been
talking again recently we always talk I
don't know why I always started to shout
out with that we've been talking
recently we're always in conversation
and I know that this past Thanksgiving
you didn't have some of your family with
you that you would have liked to have
been with you and I know there's a
little bit on the strange side but it's
part of growing up it's part of getting
older when you know family members get
married it's harder to see them and
whatnot just because you weren't with
him this Thanksgiving season
know that you are still very much loved
especially by us too and that even the
family members who weren't with you
I wish they were with you as well
because you are the bomb for the best
you could be the next spider-gwen dude
spider Delia I feel like you're destined
for some type of amazing superpower
because every once in a while you have
to deal with some physical disability
that occurs in your life but that's
usually the origins of someone who is
destined for greatness like you talked
about your hypergraphia where you have
to just non-stop right you know what
that makes for a perfect story think
about it someone who's unable to move
and then you can't help but right we're
gonna dish had something great you get
like a prophecy or something that comes
out at that point that's gonna be like
the key to defeating some super villain
and then pretty soon you're the hero
you're like the sexy version of george
RR martin dude hells yeah my game of
bones home why would why she's sexiness
okay I was I love you Oh Delia and merry
Christmas to you and you know you were a
big inspiration to I watched Charlie
Brown's Christmas so thank you all right
guys well don't forget to download a
false on the Stardust app you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell hey I already
said false and the star is that bike